birth control pills are one of the most
commonly used forms of contraception in
the united states today women in the u.s
can only access monthly birth control
pills through a prescription but that
could change within the next year in
july a french pharmaceutical company
submitted an application to the food and
drug administration for approval of what
could be the first non-emergency
over-the-counter birth control pill in
the u.s
so how does this over-the-counter option
compare to other contraception methods
and if the pill is approved how would
that change access to reproductive care
across the country first we need to
break down what's in these pills
combination and progestin-only pills are
the two main types of hormonal birth
control pills that women can access
through a prescription
the pill the fda is considering for
over-the-counter use is a progestin-only
pill which would be marketed under the
name opel it's not a brand new product
there is experience with using it dr
carolyn westhoff an ob gyn at columbia
university who has been researching
contraception for decades says the pill
could be used by most women
combination pills which contain both
estrogen and progestin are more commonly
used than progestin-only pills
one big reason for that is that the
bleeding pattern with combination pills
is more predictable
progestin-only pills generally come in
28-day packs
people typically experience one of three
bleeding patterns no bleeding at all
regular bleeding or unpredictable
bleeding
and it's difficult to determine which
one a person might experience that
irregularity might be annoying but it's
not medically dangerous
combination pills on the other hand are
typically taken on a cyclic method of
three weeks on a hormone-containing pill
and one week on an inactive pill which
is when menstruation would occur
progestin-only pills also require
patients to be more vigilant about when
they take their daily dose
that's because of how quickly the
hormone is typically metabolized in the
body
progestin prevents ovulation and works
to thicken the cervical mucus which
helps prevent sperm from reaching an egg
taking a dose late could leave the mucus
lining thin enough for sperm to get
through
impacting the pill's effectiveness
against preventing pregnancy
but the type of progestin in the opel
lasts a little longer that leads to more
stable blood levels and a little bit
more forgiveness if a woman takes her
building
combination pills are even more
forgiving so it matters less whether the
pills are taken at the same time each
day
potential side effects set the progestin
pills apart from combination pills
because combination pills have more of
what doctors call contraindications
which are conditions they consider a
reason not to take a certain medication
or treatment due to potential harm the
reason that this application for this
pill looks very appealing
is that most of the contraindications
for using birth control pills really
relate to the estrogen component and
this pill does not have estrogen so it
means that it is suitable for almost
every woman to use birth control pills
that contain estrogen can increase the
risk of developing blood clots in some
women between three and nine in every
ten thousand users of combination birth
control pills experience the blood clot
in a given year
if the pill is approved by the fda that
could make it easier for some to access
contraceptives given what's going on
with the overturning of rugby wade with
the jobs decision we expect that more
clinics might not be able to continue
providing services
that's laurie sobol the associate
director of the women's health policy
team at the kaiser family foundation she
said the change to over-the-counter
birth control would make a big
difference especially for those who
don't have access to healthcare either
virtually or in person the folks that
have insurance right now would be making
a deliberate choice to go from having
something that's covered at 100 with no
cost sharing to them to something in
which they may need to pay out of pocket
she said consumer choices would likely
depend on weighing cost versus
convenience but the price won't be set
unless the drug is approved which could
take months other manufacturers are
waiting on the sidelines to see exactly
how this gets implemented and then make
line up at the fda for other methods to
go over the counter